عرفت الشهره مبكرا بل وظهرت على الشاشه
وهي لا تزال رضيعه كذلك عرفت الضعف والالم
مبكرا فسقطت وسقطت ثم نهضت كزهره بريه
جعلت من اسمها درو باريمور على من كبيرا
في فضاءات
فما قصتها
ولدت دروبليث باريمور عام
1975 في كاليفورنيا لعائله فنيه فوالدها
جون درو باريمور وظهرت قبل ان تتم مهامها
الاول في اعلان تلفزيوني لطعام الكلاب
عندما اصبحت في الخامسه ظهرت لاول مره على
الشاشه الكبيره بفيلم
قبل ان تقدم اهم اعمالها وهو دور
الاخت الصغيره المحببه بالفيلم الناجح
ايتي ذا اكسترايل لتنطلق نحو دائره الضوء
وتحصل على فرصه لمشاركه جوني كارسن
على قناه ام بي سي في عام
1984 حدث الاسوء في حياتها عندما انفصل
والداها فعاشت تجربه صعبه كما اصطحبتها
والدتها لاحقا للانديه الليليه وهو العالم
الذي ارتبطت به وهي لا تزال في الثالثه
عشره من عمرها فبدات تعطي المخدرات
والكحول وتم وضعها في مركز اعاده التاهيل
لتعود من جديد مع مجموعه اعمال ناجحه مثل
بويسن
ستوري في عام
1995 فكرت درو في القيام بشيء كبير فاسست
مع شركتها نانسي جوفونيل شركه الانتاج
فلور فيلمز وانتجت الفيلم الكوميديه
الناجح نيفر بين كاست ثم تل العديد من
الاعمال الناجحه التي ارتدت فيها قبعه
الممثله المنتجه مثل تشارليز
انجلزك اند ليركس
وغيرها بالاضافه الى اكثر من 66 فيلما
قدمت
تلفزيونيه ناجحه مثل جري جاردنز ومسلسل
سانتا كلوريتا دايت كما كانت قاضيه في
برنامج المواهب the best قبل ان تقدم
برنامجها دجروب على قناه سي بي اس فحازت
جوائز فنيه عديده مثل جولدن جلوب وجائزه
نقابه ممثل الشاشه وحصلت على نجمه في ممشى
هوليود وجمع الثروه تزيد عن 125
مليار دولار
رغم نجاحها مهنيا عانت الدرو من
الانفصالات المتكرره حيث فسخت خطوبتها وهي
في السادسه عشره وانفصلت مرتين عن زواجين
قصيرين ومره عن زواجها الاخير بالممثل
ويلكوبلمان بعد ان انجبت منه الطفلين
مدافعها لاصدار مجموعه كتب عن حياتها كان
ابرزها
حيث تحدثت عن مراهقتها ووالد فلور الذي
وصفت فيه نفسها بالزهره البريه
[موسيقى]